i
am very excited about this possible
predators movie with dan
it's called skull right you see this is
where i wanted to know what
what can you tell me about this predator
movie well i can tell you four things
the first thing is dan is a brilliant
director um and watching dailies
you just understand how his
vision is completely unique he's got his
own language and it's fresh and it's
cool and it's interesting
secondly this is the predator origin
story
this is the predator's first
journey to this planet third is
our our lead our hero um is female
which i always think is interesting i
guess i did that with predator versus
alien rights and
lathan right um
and then the fourth thing about it is
it goes back to what made the original
predator movie work
it's it's the ingenuity of
um a human being who won't give up
who's able to observe and interpret
basically being able to beat a stronger
more powerful
well-armed force it actually has more
akin to the revenant than it does
any film in the predator canon and
you'll
you'll know what i mean once you see it
it's really great script too
it's fantastic scripts so i
i have follow-ups if you don't mind um
is it
rated r pg-13 what's what's the rate
well you know it all depends how you end
up cutting it
right um it was conceived as an r-rated
movie
it could easily end up pg-13 you know i
guess we're going to find out what it
has to be
or what it is you know when it's all cut
together what is the plan
for when you think fans will actually
see footage a trailer
when is this going to be released tbd
how far
are you into filming probably three
quarters of the way through
what's interesting about this project is
really not
a lot of information is known for
something that's actually
filming and in production right now was
this
i think dan or someone said that the
idea originally was this
like might be just a complete surprise
but information got out
what has been the i guess it's been very
quiet on this movie what was this done
on purpose like what
what's here here's the interesting thing
we started conceiving this movie while
we were shooting the last predator movie
dan came to me um with a writer and an
idea
while we were shooting the movie um
and we just kind of felt like
and emma watts was really instrumental
here she said
you know what let's go put this into
development now and let's push hard on
this now
let's go for this now and we could be
shooting one movie and prepping another
right
especially when one was the current day
end of the franchise and the other one
was
you know the period beginning of the
franchise
so it was always done with a lot of
secrecy um
and it just has continued to be
kind of you know something that's going
to be out there to surprise you
it is it is it's going to be i believe
the second best or the first or maybe
equal to the first one
right i feel like you know the first one
was a wonderful interesting movie
and i know what worked about it and i
feel like we kind of never got
back there again we ended up in
different places
i think this will this is a worthy
compliment to the first one it's going
to be as good
is it in the 1800s early 1900s have you
revealed the time period
we have not revealed the time period
it's you can use your imagination
it's it is it is early